yeah the next one yeah it's say cancer
shoe can yeah i'm near certain gantt
recommended this one
it was me are you i'm not gonna lie
i'mma say it right now boys
yeah i like i like the hentai version of
this one yeah the hentai version is
funny because
yeah dude you can't the animation alone
in the in the hentai version of this is
so goddamn good
and i was so confused when i opened this
dojin because i was like what is this
story in the start
yeah this is the [ __ ] story get to the
story i know yeah the
yeah the first story it's just like yeah
this is like so this is like a
collection of stories it's like
is it two stories it's like two or three
stories okay so there's two stories in
this it's second to shoot
and uh i think it's so the first part is
like a teacher
who [ __ ] their student story yeah yeah
yeah and like this teacher is not
not very charismatic very creepy very
rapey
really weird you know you get interested
this girl and she's a little concerned
you know
she's like why are all the guys looking
at my my big you know
big and uh you know
and this teacher's like oh don't worry
about it i'll help you i'll help you get
used to them
yeah because if you don't care about it
anymore no one's gonna look at them
and i'm like genius logic
okay and so he's like oh yeah just take
your bra off in front of me so you can
get more used to showing them off and
i'm like
oh god all right it's one of these
because it's just like it's really rapey
and like because because you get you did
recommend
the next one i will talk about is the
teacher one i think that's done much
more tastefully than this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah not a fan of
this one shot yeah the one shot i didn't
really want you to care but the one shot
was like a hundred pages long though
wrong because it's like and this is the
thing that i hate about hentai
but this happens all the goddamn time um
let me see it so so
okay one one trope that i really am not
fond of in hentai is where the girl is
like
no oh my god please don't and like
they're clearly being
i mean you know sexually assaulted
really yeah yeah and then
suddenly the you know they start doing
it and they're like oh wait i like this
now and i'm like
i don't think that's how yeah generally
did not enjoy this teacher fellow
i thought he was a little little bit
rapey a little unpleasant yeah
and like like i think i said it's an
episode not really fond of that kind of
stuff
you know to me it's just like oh okay
and he's like i'm gonna teach you how to
be more comfortable with your boobs i'm
like
are you really are you sure about did
you say like the name of the dojin
i'll tell you the name of the dojian is
abstinence club at least the first story
yard
right which is it's it's obviously
nothing about abstinence
i'm sorry no abstinence to be found here
that's quite the opposite
you know these are not good christian
girls you know that's that's not what
we're talking about here
and there's two things that personally i
i i i'm not really
fond of or i just i'm like ah whatever
that come up in this the sturgeon
uh first one being uh that apparently
dick can just convert your feelings
entirely and that you can just suddenly
love it once it's inside of you i'm like
pretty sure that's not how it works
uh whatever it's gonna be pretty [ __ ]
good for you to do that you'd be
surprised about
how many times that pop that crops up in
hentai
single [ __ ] i know where it's just
like huh you don't want it
well you haven't you obviously haven't
had the giga chad dig
let me introduce you say that after you
feel about it
yeah and then also they have that whole
[ __ ] trope of uh for some reason this
happens a lot in hentai as well where
um you know the girl is having sex with
the teacher because of course she is
yeah and outside is another student who
happens to catch wind of this going on
and naturally instead of being like oh
god oh my god and running away and
telling friends she's like
i think i should i think i should start
nutting i think i should start
masturbating right now
right now outside outside multiple times
either winter or or summer in japan
which are both wildly uncomfortable
seasons to be doing this outside by the
way
so this is just a terrible experience
overall and i did not enjoy this first
story at all i thought it was [ __ ]
and i was really confused i was like i
meant i really like the anime version of
this i thought it was really hot
i didn't even remember this that this
had an anime adaptation because like
i had to like i was i was seeing no no
exactly exactly because i
i was like this name kind of rings a
bell yeah i'm saying
i look at the anime and then i look at
the dojin and i'm just like
these aren't the same for a minute i
literally thought i had made a mistake
and like they adapted the better half
into yeah yeah
thanks thankfully because the first half
is every other [ __ ] dojin that exists
yeah
yeah and every hentai all right whatever
[ __ ] teacher abuses power yeah
yeah yeah whatever whatever whatever
we'll get to